grayscale pictures from interplanetary
space were actually sent back from Mars
to earth in from the mid 60's onwards
and yeah I mean we call these
black-and-white pictures as you all know
by now they're not they're really
grayscale pictures the scale used at the
time was one of 64 shades and I put that
there
black was shade 63 actually hello
they're just probably just off the page
use shade zero which is white
interplanetary space and you're
transmitting radio signals with the
shades of grey on it's a very noisy
place there's actually gamma rays cosmic
rays jembelina solar sunspots flares
everything the amount of radio noise is
quite considerable and what this means
is that typically up to 25% of your
shade of grey pixels in your photos can
get corrupted in flight if you look at
these two pictures that one there is
actually very fuzzy and then you look at
the sky you might think oh there's lots
and lots of quasars and tiny starvin no
it's not it's noise and if you compare
it with the other one it's being cleaned
up you can see the contours on Mars are
sharper the sky is much blacker so
that's the idea then you've got noisy
photos and noisy grayscale pictures
being sent back how do you correct them
and get them to look really really good
the only Mariners just did a flyby of
the planets
I think Meredith three unbelievable this
did a flyby and then transmitted the
results back at 8 bits per second for a
200 by 200 pixel array it only took
eight hours part of the problem of space
being so noisy is that you cannot start
having megabits per second between the
planets in fact dr. Bagla dr. Steve was
talking to me about this yesterday and
saying what bitrate did they get on
Mariner 9
and the answer is 16 kilobits per second
also don't forget that at the time that
the Mariner 9 venture took place roughly
speaking it took radio signals nine
minutes to get from Earth to Mars now
you realize this is a moveable feast
because it depends where Earth and Mars
are relative to one another in their
orbits I think I looked up it can be
anything between 6 minutes and 23
minutes and Mariner 909 minutes so the
other thing to say is to those of you
skeptics who say oh we got a corrupted
picture why not send back a signal and
ask it to transmit again are you joking
you can dispense you know it took
memories to get even 9 minutes to get a
not angle a signal back to Mars and then
wait another nine minutes to hopefully
get the best one that doesn't get
corrupted 27 minutes no I mean you can
forget any idea of tight interaction
with planetary spacecraft you cannot do
that and this I think does bring it home
to those of you so well if in doubt just
send it again no you can't do that here
is the real case where you've got to
pack enough check bits around the
message that you can clean it up without
asking for a retransmit even when you've
got the pictures back and you'll see all
this corruption you think oh heck how
clever can I be how am I going to clean
these up and let me just remind you once
again about how you measure payload
versus correction bits and so on and
then I'll reveal to you what ratio is
between those were actually used in
Mariner 9 n K D notation that is total
number of bits per codeword the code
word is basically saying here is the
package it's got the message bits in it
packed around with
apparently checking to make sure
it gets through okay and the idea of
this game is to keep the codewords
as far distant as possible and by
distance what we're saying is take a
codeword take another code word look at
how many places in the bit pattern are
different and that is your distance and
the bigger you can keep that distance
apart the more chance you have that the
corruption and damage won't mislead you
slight you want to send a parcel of eggs
somewhere you know how much parking you
fulfill isn't it because I'm physically
how follows is how far apart are they
exactly so and of course the further
apart you put your eggs the bigger the
package gets with lots of fluffy wooly
stuff in keeping them apart from one
another yeah it's it's quite right
that's exactly what it is
okay so total bits per codeword is n K
is the message bits the payload the ones
that really can these are the things
that are going to communicate which of
your 64 shades of grey that pixel is and
just remember because it's sobering
every one of these great long strings we
send is giving you the color of one
pixel Mariner six time it was a 200 by
200 grid by Mariner 9 you say you make a
rod for your own back it had gone up to
700 by 832 not perhaps quite as good as
modern videos Greenville you know
getting there so back to this then D is
that distance I was telling you about
the people at Jet Propulsion Laboratory
have got a lot of really really good
communications engineers who are also
coding theorists and what they came up
with a code to answer all of these
conflicting claims was one where the
overall message length is 32 bits packed
inside that is a six bit message
carefully hidden and carefully protected
and the distance is a
amazing it's 16 for those of you still
with us who are computer scientists the
reason we've got six here is at 2 to the
power 6 2 times 2 times 2 times 3 6
times over is the magic 64 which we
number from 0 to 63 because we're
computer scientists and everything
starts at 0 this distance will give you
a figure number of correctable errors
remember the CD and here's my little bit
of mathematical notation floor of D
minus 1 over 2 what does floor mean I'll
tell you in a minute but let's work out
the four little formula in the middle my
D value is 60 ok so on this occasion I'm
finding the floor off 15 over 2 15 over
2 7.5 floor of means if you've got a
decimal part to your number in there
then round everything down it doesn't
matter even if it's seven point eight it
would round down so floor means round
down ceiling is forcibly rounding up
what we're doing Floria floor 7 point 5
is 7 so this is amazing performance out
of what is saying is that in these
32-bit packages you can have up to 7
bits go wrong and there you always say
it's 25% the reason they chose this was
they knew that roughly speaking you
could get up to 25% errors depending on
whether it was a good day or bad day for
cosmic rays at the moment you know but
this really worked well 32 bits were in
the 1960s older viewers will know
heaven-sent that fits into an IBM
mainframe world because powerful
computers in those days really expensive
ones and even the newly emerging deck
mini mainframes had 32 bits on his old
hat now everything 32 bits being phased
out in favor of 64 but this fitted so
well you got a 32 bit package six of
those hidden bits in there carrying the
message silk to seven correctable errors
inside here and this particular code is
very famous because it had been proposed
way way back before the mayor
program in the 1950s as a good way of
getting lots of error correction going
inside a transmitted packet oh and by
the way even on Mariners you know the
camera could gather information faster
than it could ever be transmitted so the
Mariners have a little tape recorder on
board and they tape recorded the scan of
the picture and then trickle it out
overnight at 16 kilobits per second
overnight over night presumably so it's
been a story that's gone on now for the
best part of 50 more years and I think
it's a good place to stop but some of
you I know will want to follow up saying
he'll now the reed-muller code words
because I want to do it for myself well
today is hardcore coding theory
relatively speaking it's still 64 shades
of grey for those of you looking for the
sequel and remember the secret is always
better than the original thing